this video is sponsored by nordvpn
in any good rpg one of the primary goals
is to create your perfect build your
perfect character with all the stats
that you want maxed out as far as you
can go
this is how i think we should also
approach our training i'm not the first
person to notice this parallel but there
are some things i wanted to say about it
because you see a lot of people don't
approach their training like this
instead they just go with whatever
training program they've been given
whichever one they can download or find
on the internet and then they stick with
that their goals are nothing more than
to just get fitter and to get into shape
maybe lose weight get stronger
but instead if we approach this like we
might an rpg we can look at the
different stats that we have and then
decide which ones we want to focus on
what do we want to improve do we want to
be faster do we want to jump higher do
we want to be stronger maybe we want a
combination of those things but where's
the weighting which thing is going to
take priority and what can you have at
the same time this way you can come up
with a kind of perfect build and then
you can work backwards to select the
exercises you need from there and that's
always what i've done
this is why i devised the 80 nsp
hierarchy
in this video i'm going to talk a little
bit about how we might go about maxing
out our stats and some of the ways we
might treat life and training like an
rpg in order to get ahead a little bit
faster using some of the same principles
that work in that context
so if we're treating training like an
rpg we might use some of the same
strategies that we use in an rpg in
order to succeed and the first one of
these i want to talk about is something
called min maxing so when you min max in
an rpg basically going to pour all of
your experience points into a single
skill or traitor attribute for example
you might make a build of a character
that's extremely strong or that's
extremely smart but you do this at the
expense of all the other traits that you
might have invested some of those points
into this results in a very lopsided
character and of course there are
benefits to doing this because you can
make the strongest character possible or
you can create a character disabled just
sneak past all of those opponents
but i think it's a mistake because
ultimately there is always a chance
you're going to come across a door that
needs you know level 100 intellects to
open or you're going to come across an
opponent that needs you to be stronger
and in that scenario you're going to
regret having invested all of those
experience points into a single thing
how does this apply to the real world
and real training well in case the
connection wasn't obvious this of course
is precisely the choice you have to make
when you decide whether or not you want
to be a bodybuilder a power lifter a
ultra marathon runner or some kind of
hybrid athlete i believe that by
training across different modalities or
at least to try and gain as wide a range
of different skills as possible you
literally give yourself more freedom and
more options also important if you're
playing games online is to make sure
that you have good internet security and
one of the best ways you can do this is
with a vpn such as today's sponsor
nordvpn so nordvpn is a virtual private
network that means that it provides you
with secrecy when you're browsing the
web it does this by allowing you to
connect to the web via one of their
servers instead of going straight to the
website that you want to visit your
traffic is instead relayed via that
server this not only allows you to hide
your ip address from the internet but it
also allows you to hide your browsing
activity from your ispn your internet
service provider not saying that these
websites or your ispn have got nefarious
schemes but they do collect a lot of
data and i mean it's private why should
anyone know the websites that you want
to visit and of course it can protect
you from malicious attacks at the same
time being able to spoof your address
and make it appear as though you're
coming from another country means that
you can access content that is region
locked that means programs and shows on
things like netflix you otherwise
wouldn't be able to view and what's most
this won't slow down your viewing
experience because nordvpn has the
fastest times according to the latest
speed tests versus other providers by
any of you can get access to an
exclusive deal by going to nordvpn.com
forward slash the bioneer and there's a
30-day money-back guarantee so you're
not taking any risks at all check that
link out in the description down below
and thanks once again to nordvpn for
sponsoring this video
i think that creating a build like this
is going to involve too much training
because you're too scattered all over
the place however if you create that
build and you know exactly what you want
and work backwards to choose the right
exercises you can find those exercises
that provide multiple benefits and
benefit you in multiple domains that way
you're choosing bang for your buck
exercises and that way you're being more
time efficient and training across
multiple domains now of course there is
a trade-off here and of course there's
only a certain degree to which you can
get stronger without it affecting your
cardio for example however i think this
is a trade-off that's worth making and
part of the fun is discovering where
that balance is and which exercises help
you to optimize it
another tip that applies perfectly here
is to play at your own level play at the
right level because in rpgs you can
effectively select your own difficulty
and you can do this by going to a point
in the game where there's lots of very
difficult enemies or sticking to areas
where there are weaker enemies typically
we stick to the weaker areas and then as
we progress and level up our character
we can that way explore the more
dangerous areas
however by setting your own difficulty
you can also fall into a number of traps
for one you might stick around in the
easy area for too long and thereby not
to grow your character's stats as you
should be on the other hand though if
you go too quickly to the more difficult
areas you're just going to be
slaughtered and have your ass handed to
you over and over again not getting any
experience points lose your resources
and also possibly lose your interest in
the game because it's pretty
soul-crushing and hopefully you can
right away see the parallels here with
training because when you're training
you also set your own difficulty you
choose how heavy to make the weight how
many exercises to do what kind of
cadence to use you can use light weights
to blast out reps not make it that
difficult you're not really going to
gain that many experience points from
work out like that and you won't see the
gains come as quickly as they should do
you're just spinning your wheels and
massaging your ego alternatively you
might pile loads of weight on and
perform an exercise with poor form and
that can lead to injury so we need to
find that sweet point where it's just
difficult enough to provide growth but
not so difficult that it's soul crushing
and actually game designers have to
think about this when they design their
games they have to keep the game at the
perfect difficulty level as you progress
through it this keeps you in a flow
state because when something's too easy
we'll lose attention when something's
too hard we lose the will to progress
when something's just right we can enter
a flow state where we feel focused
rewarded for our input and challenged
just the right amount this is what you
want from your training you want to pick
just the right difficulty level and
really be honest with yourself about
where you're at
another tip i've learned from playing
rpgs when it comes to building your
ideal athletic build is to think in
terms of the big wins and not to fret
the small stuff and this is something
that's a big issue i think is rife in
the fitness industry in an rpg or a game
you need to grind you need to build up
your stats over time and some of this is
going to be menial it's going to be
chipping away at bigger stats you don't
want to be strategic you want to spend
your time doing things that can give you
the maximum benefit for the time that
you invest and great examples of this
are scenarios and games where you get a
big step change in terms of your power
these really empowering moments in zelda
it might be getting the master sword
in cyberpunk 2077 i realized that if i
was able to get one sniper rifle from
one of the bad guys i could then hang
back and pick off enemies from a
distance and get much higher value loot
my point with all this when it relates
to real life is that you need to be
careful of these biohacks and these
supplements and these tips that promise
to gain you like two percent
testosterone or three percent more
energy or cut your sprint time down by
you know half a fraction of a
millisecond these things can be very
tempting because they're hacks they
involve less work and we think that by
doing this one thing we're gonna get an
edge over our competition you know how
many people do you know who lie on spiky
mats before bed who take cold showers
even things like the wim hof method and
i'm not saying these things don't work
or have their place but if you're doing
all of these things trying to optimize
your performance but you haven't just
focused on the basics on building a lot
of strength by going to the gym then
you're really missing out likewise get
more sunlight get outside more if you
want to increase your vitamin d and your
testosterone because really three
percent increase in testosterone might
sound amazing in a study but a that's a
study it's far removed from reality and
b
that's not going to make a big impact on
your life because three percent is just
a tiny drop in the ocean
and of course there are certain
exercises that are going to provide you
with far more benefit than others you
might waste your time doing an exercise
that isn't particularly beneficial to
you when you could be doing something
that's going to progress you much faster
much further like lately i've been doing
proper planche leans just holding for
static time i've just seen so much more
progress in my straight arm training
than i did when i was just bashing out
rep after rep of tuck planche dips
another much more simple takeaway from
all this is that everything can be
trained when you play an rpg you see
traits like charisma technology
intelligence stealth these can be
upgraded just like you can upgrade your
strength or your speed in real life we
often just focus on strength or
aesthetics as this one global trait when
actually there are so many other things
that we can train any aspect of yourself
you want to improve pretty much there
are a few exceptions you can improve the
body is extremely adaptable in that way
so don't just focus on strength and
speed have a look at agility balance
reflexes mobility and even things like
brain power and focus and beyond this we
can go into the far more detailed
minutia as well because sure you can
improve brain function but even within
that you have things like working memory
inhibitory control all these different
aspects of yourself that you can train
specifically if you know how and if you
do the research
and my final tip if you want to train
and live as though life were an rpg it's
a corny one but just try and enjoy the
game because of course the whole point
of any rpg is that it's a game and
you're supposed to enjoy it we're
actually seeing this in game design game
designers have to install ways to
prevent gamers from just hacking the
systems if they find one weapon that
works too well they'll only use that
weapon and win the game this is actually
ruining it for themselves because
they're not enjoying the game so much
and we can apply the same logic to
training and to life more broadly sure
certain choices might get to your
destination quicker when it comes to
your lifestyle goals your training goals
however if you hate doing it along the
way then was it really worth it as long
as you're heading in the right direction
try and enjoy yourself as much as
possible i think that's super important
for training because i mean the great
thing about an rpg if it's done well is
that you will put in the hours and you
will level up because it's inherently
fun if your training is inherently fun
you'll level up as well eventually
you'll be unstoppable
so i hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around that would
help me out immensely let me know in the
comments down below if you see training
almost like an rpg and what traits and
attributes you're specifically focusing
on leveling up i'd also like to know
what your favorite computer games are
if you're interested in training away
that doesn't just focus on one thing
like strength or speed but that allows
you to level up in multiple areas all at
once you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 the protein performance
system this training program is designed
to train everything from speed to
strength to mobility to brain function
all at once in a simple and easy to
follow program you get an 80 plus page
ebook a program that you can print out
as well as over two hours of video
tutorial and there's a big discount on
that right now right now it's available
for just 19.99 which is to celebrate the
fact that the channel just crossed 600
000 subscribers thank you so much guys
for making that possible it's a huge
honor i still can't believe it and yeah
what can i say obviously wouldn't be
possible without you guys by definition
so thank you so so much for your support
also like to take a moment to say thank
you to paul from first for fitness in
vista who created this incredible batman
bust for me i'm currently kitting out my
office trying to make some cool
backdrops and different corners of the
room look good it's a work in progress
but this thing is definitely going to be
one of the highlights and if you're
interested in getting one commissioned
for yourself then he is considering
taking orders like that so i'll put his
email and description down below contact
him if you want something similar
yourself either way guys thank you so
much again for watching and for
everything and i'll see you next time
bye for now
you